[Musica]
la cosa che mi diverte oggi che sono qui
come relatore mi diverte perché è un
titolo che nessuno mi ha dato mai ma
perché in realtà non è un merito allora
un relatore uno che si relazionano che
fa cose per illuminare le menti ma c'è
stata un po di confusione evidentemente
cioè si pensa che se come uno parla al
microfono può fare tutto entro quel
microfono microfono è un oggetto freddo
dentro ci puoi recitare
ci puoi cantare dentro poi annunciare ma
qui non c'è nessun annuncio da fare
non c'è nessun film da doppiare non c'è
nessuna canzone da cantare
però c'è un tema io quando sono su cosa
sono stato invitato non volevo venire un
po perché effettivamente questo non è il
mio mestiere e quindi non so che cosa
dirò mi sono scritto due cose ma ho
dovuto lavorare perché io in realtà sono
un operaio non a caso quelli nostri si
chiamano turni quelli del doppio dove si
chiama turni ora sono tornato a casa
alle dieci di sera e ho pensato è tra
l'altro io adesso qui mi voglio sfogare
perché basta con questa dizione questa
articolazione questo italiano neutro e
mo che khassidica assaggi
c'era il tema abruzzo forte e gentile
ho saputo che una frase di primo levi
perché me l'ha detta nemico mio conto
pensavo in realtà e non sto dicendo una
bugia pensavo fosse una frase di
d'annunzio dedicata al parrozzo
piuttosto ma verame piuttosto che che
che ne so una fra uno slogan di un amaro
fatto con le erbe del del gran sasso
l'abruzzo è forte come posso dire è
troppo forte diciamo della sua ancora
gentile invisibilità spacciata spesso
per unicità l'abruzzo e forte dei suoi
muri difensivi che non hanno mai difeso
nessuno ma anzi hanno piuttosto invitato
la gente ad andarsene a cercarsi
qualcosa di interessante fuori di qui
l'abruzzo è forte perché la bruzzone dei
bisogni ring e the name e tutta la
montagna lo mara la collina e li l'olio
migliore il vino migliore ed è vero
nessuno toglie all'abruzzo queste cose
però se questa diciamo se questo
incontro vuole essere la possibilità di
di uno spunto e con lo spunto che io
porterei oggi è molto semplice molto
banale e l'opportunità di aprirsi al
mondo cioè dopo carsoli oricola c'è un
mondo
ok che fa cose e le fa anche bene non
sono tutti quanti non solo tutti quanti
da disprezzare mi arrabbio perché
l'abruzzese è veramente forte però è
forte solo quando sta fuori dall'abruzzo
quando sta qua deve fare il campanilista
sono passato prima di venire qui
tra l'altro ve la racconto brevemente mi
stavano uccidendo 20 cani perché il
navigatore non sodoma mannate a un certo
punto c'era st strada di campagna dice
vabbè quattro minuti di più uscirò la
strada chiusa 20 cani intorno per
fortuna sono riuscito a fare manovra con
la macchina altrimenti sarei stato
sbranato vivo
ditelo agli animalisti
allora arrivò dico quindi adesso bisogna
parlare questa brutta gente dove dolce
forte e gentile
qui dicevo l'abruzzo e gentile della sua
storia che gli passa accanto ma che poi
non mette mai radici allora dicevo che
fuori dall'abruzzo ci sono delle cose
interessanti e l'opportunità
secondo me è lo spunto di riflessione
deve essere quello di aprirsi agli altri
di pensare che gli altri qualche volta
possono anche essere più capaci di noi
gli altri possono fare delle cose
interessanti e noi confrontandoci non
solo capiamo di più ma se noi ci
confrontiamo con l'altro ci facciamo
conoscere
ok e se noi ci facciamo conoscere
qualcuno finalmente riuscirà ad indicare
col dito sulla cartina geografica
addossa l'abruzzo che qualche anno fa lo
scambiavano per la basilicata e il
molise e altre regioni semi dimenticate
allora noi ci dobbiamo aprire a una
cultura maggiore allora negli anni la
politica qui ha fatto abbastanza schifo
la politica si occupa da soltanto di
costruire un un ospedale per ogni
campanile perché la sanità era una cosa
interessante dove ci si poteva sguazzare
alla grande facciamo anche altre cose
però non chiudiamoci dentro di noi
dicendo cannon 6 meno perché non se meno
a bottero tradotta in italiano e mi
veniva fuori
scusa se esistono ok mi veniva fuori
perdonami allora questa frase non è
sufficiente
come non sono sufficienti cevo quando
prima dei cani ho visto via ignazio
silone mi sono ricordato che qui abbiamo
avuto dei grandi dei grandi esponenti
del pensiero liberale
ok silone benedetto croce lo stesso
pannella
eppure nonostante tutto qui aleggia
ancora da sempre una mentalità schifosa
che è quella dell'assistenzialismo a me
giada panzano stata a me lo stato non ci
ha pensato mai se non quando dovevo
presentare l'f24 per pagare l'irpef en
en en aereo l'f24
ok allora io mi sento di dire
soprattutto ai giovani perché quelli
della mia generazione sono fottuti i
nostri padri
qualcuno forse si sta godendo una
decente vecchiaia altri meno i giovani
però devono reagire
i giovani si devono aprire al mondo e
devono pensare che non è vero a
sambatello volesse andranno bustarelle
adunanze fanuc ad allora queste frasi
qui io non le voglio sentire più
purtroppo io queste cose le dico perché
continuo a sentirmi come sono dato 28
anni fa continua a sentire dei giovani
che sono nati dopo che io ero partito
che parlano come i loro bisnonni questo
non va bene
non possiamo continuare a pensare che
sempre qualcun altro si debba occupare
di noi perché non mettiamo sul campo un
sogno e proviamo a realizzarlo dandosi
da fare e non pensando che l'altro che
ci sta fottendo noi è vero abbiamo un
olio straordinario un vino straordinario
ma non è possibile che tu vendi il tuo
olio ix viii da me catene venga 50
centesimi di meno pensando di fregare il
tuo vicino di casa
ti stai fottendo da solo ti stai
fottendo da solo perché io poi vado in
toscana e lo pago 18 18 euro al litro
cerchiamo di mettere in evidenza quello
che abbiamo
facendosi rispettare e usciamo da questo
imbarazzo perché qui c'è un grande
imbarazzo che sarà dato dalla storia
venivano i popoli frentani peligni
venivano equa bomb e quindi abbiamo
paura dello straniero sradichiamo questa
cosa dal nostro dna
questo mi sento di dire soprattutto ai
giovani io faccio
scuola di recitazione di doppiaggio da
15 anni a pescara però negli anni io e
roberto pedicini gli altri insegnanti ci
siamo espansi e abbiamo tante altre
città i ragazzi abruzzesi sono buoni
sono dei bravi ragazzi ma sono chiusi
quando tu ti devi aprire un altro
tu devi condividere la sua mentalità in
maniera libera non lo puoi fare sempre
sotto l'ala del giudizio che cosa dirà
mio padre mia madre il mio vicino di
casa quando gli diciamo dovete imparare
a parlare in italiano perché il
doppiaggio non lo puoi fare se parli in
abruzzese ma nemmeno ha giustamente in
toscano in veneto quello che è però dopo
i quando vayer agendo mar frega io
questo mi sento di dire questa sera che
dobbiamo reagire a questa paura
dell'altro
io penso che sia più una paura che poi
diventa aggressività c'è la difesa a
tutti i costi di quello che abbiamo noi
così siccome 3m top dove dobbiamo andare
qualche anno fa ma neanche qualche forse
l'anno scorso mi chiamo un regista amico
mio
bravo ragazzo di usa e dobbiamo unire
tutte queste forze
ok tutte queste tutti questi artisti
abruzzesi si devono unire isa tosi sono
operai però vabbè mi consideri artista
mi fa piacere
cosa dobbiamo fare uno spot per
l'abruzzo ok no non ce l'ho io non lo
voglio fare
non voglio fare niente io perché non ve
lo meritate
non lo voglio fare perché tanto non
accadrà nulla ma stai scherzando tu lo
fai per me io per te lo farei ma non lo
voglio fare perché non succede niente
stai sereno non succede niente hanno
fatto lo spot ma certo punto lo vedo c'è
lui non faccio i nomi guarda lei lei non
è un'attrice abruzzese hanno messo una
de roma uno spot per l'abruzzo una da
roma
guardala adriatico si gira adesso non mi
ricordo esattamente ma tipo e dopo la
gente se ne va le maldive ma le mattine
animative adriatico l'adriatico di
pescara con gli sversamenti d'estate non
potete fare un bagno perché c'è il
divieto di balneazione mese d'agosto
sono andato ma che succede se devo con
lui tutto incazzate ci aveva giustamente
lo stabilimento balneare non c'è nessuno
ma che fate non dite niente cattivo di
come che cazzo perché ti devi mettere a
pecora perché devi fare il pecorone non
è possibile due anni gli sversamenti ci
sarà qualcuno responsabile degli
sversamenti a ruba ma niente non fa
niente
e questo spot non è andato da nessuna
parte come io pensavo
magari mi fosse sbagliata nei fatti la
serata politici già saturo cerchi non lo
trovi sa ma tira voleva sentirsi
abbattuto per essere più preciso non
l'ho trovato
c'è solo backstage 30 filmati di
backstage e abbiamo fatto questo filmato
le cose ma che cazzo filmata tosta non
soltanto le interviste politici gente li
papillon
voi avete fatto uno spot per che
volevate fare una serata e allora di
pharus 4 perché voglio andare sul palco
col papillon e io ti aiuto ma dimmi la
verità perché questo sport non va da
nessuna parte perché l'abruzzo non lo
conosce nessuno e mi dispiace che da
qualche anno questa regione conosciuta
solo per un cazzo di terremoto
devastante che ci ha tritato le gambe e
il cuore vi voglio bene
[Applauso]